Sen
hiç Merhabalar
bu kaybettikçe kazanmak konulu yılmazlık
Öyküm sizinle paylaşmak istiyorum beş
yaşında spor hayatına başladım ve spor
hayatımın 18 yılı yüzme ile geç tipi ilk
milli formayı sekiz yaşında Yıldız video
olaraktan aldım ve devam eden sürecin
içerisinde yurtiçinde birçok Türkiye
şampiyonluğu ve Türkiye rekoru kazandım
ama Aynen yurt dışında da aynı şekilde
birçok başarıya imza attım olimpik bir
sporcu olaraktan da yüzme kariyerimi
bıraktım ama en önemlisi şu üniversite
maalesef sıkıntılı bir süreç Yani bir
tercih hakkı kullanmak durumunda
kalıyorsunuz ve ben yaptığım branşın
ağırlığından dolayı spor hayatını
birazcık daha durdurmak durumunda kaldım
vb üniversite noktası içerisinde
hayatıma devam ettim üniversiteyi
bitirdikten sonra o heyecan hala devam
ediyordu içinde ve ne yapabilirim diye
düşünürken de orada tek bir noktada
birleştirdim havuza gitmem gerekiyor
dedim ve havuza gitmem gerekiyor Ben bir
baktım ki palet ve yüzen arkadaşlarımızı
gördüm ki bu beni çok heyecanlandırdı
Çünkü o yaş grubu içerisinde tekrardan
yüzmeye geri dönmek bir macera ile
verilmiştir daha farklı bir branş ama
sudan kopamam gerekiyordu işte ondan
dolayı da paletli yüzme ile yavaş yavaş
haşır neşir olmaya başladım ki yapmış
olduğum yüzme içerisinde de kelebekçi
olduğum için de Dolphin ağırlıklı
olduğundan monopalet dediğimiz branşı
içerisinde çok hızlı adaptasyon sağladım
ve on yıl içerisinde de hemen bir
Türkiye şampiyonluğu ve Türkiye rekoru
kazandım işte artık tamamiyle o sektörün
içerisinde girmiştim yani paletli yüzme
de liderliği noktasına gelmiştim ama
enlemsel şu Tabii ki bir ülke
vitrini sporu ile ve sanatıyla
oluşturuyor ve bizler de hak ettiğimiz
dediğimiz noktayı milli duygularla milli
formalı Mary milli forma altında
yurtdışında bu branşı tehdit etmekle
gösteriyordu kamama bu sefer maalesef
Oil bir şekilde milli takım eşofmanı
bana verilmedi herhangi bir sebep
verilmeden ve oyalı o şekilde geliş K
geçirdim ve bir yıl sonra tekrardan aynı
heyecanı kaybetmeden tekrardan yarışmaya
girdim ve maalesef O yılda iki branşta
Türkiye şampiyonu ve Türkiye rekortmeni
olaraktan gelebilir eşofman verilmedi
bir yıl sonra tekrardan pes etmeyerek
vazgeçmeyerek tekrardan girdim ve
maalesef tekrardan Bana üç branşta bu
sefer Türkiye şampiyonu Türkiye'de korku
olaraktan gelen milli Şok'tan verilmedi
ve dördüncü yılda da maalesef ayağımda
yani Sağ ayağımda çekme yaptı ve
yarışmadan ilk defa hayatım boyunca yani
18 yıllık yüzme kariyerimde ve yattı
artı serbest özür diyorum Monopoly
kariyerimde hiç Ben bırakmıştım herhangi
bir şekilde spor yarışmayı ve maalesef
orada bırakmak zorunda kaldı ve bu benim
için çok önemli bir pozisyonda Neden
Çünkü en büyük başarı sağlamış Ken neden
milli takıma giremiyorum ve neden bana
bunun gerekçesi verilmiyor diye bir
şekilde düşünme noktasına gelmiştim ve
daha sonra da tekrardan
yurtdışına çalışma tempo devam ederek
ten bir şekilde ara verdim ve ayağımın
geçmesini bekledim ve o heyecan da bu
sefer İstanbula bir babamların olduğu
yer Çanakkale ve oranın Güzelyalı
belgesine geçtim ve çalışma telefon
bitirdikten sonra da tabii ki çok ciddi
bir hareketin içerisinden bir anda yeşil
ve mavinin yani doğanın içerisine
girdiğimiz zaman da işte beklediğim
huzur buymuş dedim ve ailemle Tabii ki
bu huzur Ben de gördükten sonra hemen
anında
Sen bana bir ateşleme yaptılar dediler
ki işte Çanakkale'de bir kulüp var orada
denizde yüzüyorlar ve onlarla beraber
bir antrenman noktası içerisinde en
azından sosyalleşebilirim synway yaşım
zaman 2003 ve böyle bir aileye sahip
olmanın da gururunu taşıyorum onu da
söyleyebilirim ve ben tabii ki ne
yaptığımı sadece sosyalleşmek noktası
içerisinde dalıp çıkıyoruz suyun
altından gidiyoruz nefes tutma yapıyoruz
ama ne yaptığımı bilmiyorum hangi branşı
içerisinde yer aldığı bilmiyorum ve
hatta hangi federasyona bağlı olduğunu
bilmeden
antrenmanlarına ve sosyallik içerse
devam ettim hala en önemlisi şu yıl
sonunda gene bir şampiyonaya katıldım ve
bu şampiyonluk içerisinde gene Türkiye
şampiyonu ve Türkiye rekortmeni olmuştum
branşında içerisinde ve en önemlisi de
Avrupa rekorunu üzerinde bir derece
vurmuştum ve Tabiki birincilik kürsüsüne
çıktı zaman yaptığım branşın serbest
dalış olduğu anons bu ve serbest dalış
branşın Artık yeni Türkiye şampiyonu ve
Türkiye korku değilim ve Tabi ki bu Ben
de ayrı bir mutluluk yaşadı bu sefer
milli takımı yakalayacağım dedim ama bir
baktım ki aynı federasyon aynı
federasyon başkanı karşında ve maalesef
O yılda milli takıma giremedim ama
ve o anda artık bir duruş sergilemek
zorundayız Çünkü başarılıydım
Ben kendime güveniyordum bir yıl mı
yordum
antrenmanlarına devam ediyorum ve artık
yaşta bir olgunluk noktasına gelmiştir
ve sebep istedim araya Birçok kişiyi
koydum ve bana Sebep olarak şu söylendi
üzerimde taşıdığım dövmelerden dolayı
milli takıma giremiyordum ya dövmeleri
sildirecek Team ya da maalesef iyi bir
takıma bu şekilde gidecek işte bu Ben de
büyük bir algı bozukluğuna
bu sebebiyet verdi ve artık daha hızlı
bir şekilde daha duruşu dik bir şekilde
Ben dedim dövmeleri sildirmem Ama bu
Türkiye'de branşı lideri olacağım dedim
bu ve devam ettim vazgeçmedim yılmadım
her akıttığım perde her soluduğum Hava
da her attığın kulaçta tek bir şehir
ekledim O şans bana verilecek queo Şans
bana verildiği zamanda hazır olmak
zorundayım
bu işte 2006 yılına geldiğimiz zaman
yani milli takıma giremediğin tam gene
üç yıl daha geçti toplamda yedi yıl
olmuştur
2006 yılında artık bir şeyleri
değiştirmem gerekiyor bir şeylerin
dengesini artık kendini kurmam gerekiyor
dedim ailem bu nokta içerisinde Bana çok
ciddi derecede
destek verdi ama yapmış olduğum geceler
o kadar artık yükselmişti ki dünya
seviyesinde dereceler olduğu için de
artık Yavaş yavaş beni destekleyenler
sponsorlar da devreye girmeye başlamıştı
ve 2006 yılında ortak bir karara girmek
durumunda kaldık bir şekilde kendimi
yurtdışına atmam gerekiyordu Ve bunu ne
yapabilirim bireysel bir dünya rekor
denemesi yapmam lazım bu dünya rekor
denemesi içerisinde o zaman yani 2006
yılında iki branş çok popülerdi
bunlardan bir tanesi Deniz branşı Bir
tane de havuz branşı Deniz branşı
derinlik isteyen bir branşlı ama tecrübe
isteyen bir bıraktı Çan Bu kitabın
biliyor bilmiyorum video bilen var mı 13
akıntısı olan ve fazla derinliği olmayan
çırpıntısı bol rüzgarda Hiç kesilmeyen
bir ortam Yani benim derinlik Yapma
şansım Maalesef yok tecrüben yok ve
derinlik yapacağım alanda yok ve o zaman
ikinci branş neydi nefes tutma oy nefes
tutma branşında ise o zamana kadar saati
Deniz koşullarında çalışıyorduk Neden
Çünkü Çanakkale gibi bir ilimizde o
zamanlarda havuz yok
şimdi yapmış olduğum en iyi derece
denizde yapmış olduğum en iyi derece
dört buçukta kaydı ama kırmak istediğim
dünya rekoru 8 dakika altı saniyede yani
müthiş bir macera ama bir atımlık kurşun
var Ve ben bunu değerlendirmek istiyorum
ve bunu değerlendirebilecek hamleyle
yapmak istiyorum ve
ve en yakın bana dediğim branş nefes
tutma üzerine olduğu için de hemen
konfederasyona bir mail yazısı yazın
ve akşamı mail yazısı bana şu şekilde
geri döndü Konfederasyon
bu bağlı olduğunuz ülkemizin bağlı
olduğu federasyon var ve bu
federasyondan bu tarz yazışmaları ya
federasyon üzerinden bu tarz
çalışıyorlar yapın diye Ben de tabii ki
federasyonumuzun maalesef Eğer bu tarz
bir sıkıntısı var benim üzerimde ama
yapmış olduğum bu zamana kadarki bütün
dereciler bunlardır deyip karşı bir mail
attım ve bu mail yanıtsız kalmadı dedi
ki bizleri her şekilde de sporcunun ve
senin yanındayız Ondan dolayı eğer bu
rekor denemesi yapmak istiyorsan Biz
kendi gözlemlerinizi size yollayacağız
ve rahat rahat tabure Koru
yapabilirsiniz işte bir atımlık kurşun
vardı doğru yere gitti ama bakalım ne
kadar gerçeği bi ve hayatında hiç
yapmadım ama ideolojik nokta içerisinde
şunu net bir şekilde söyleyebilirim
dünya rekoru kırmak değil Amacım
Gerçekten ve gerçekten hak ettim
yıllarca bunun için savaştığı milli
takım eşortmanlı alıp Bu bir şekilde
yurt dışında kendini gösterebilecek
statü yakalayabilmek işte Maalesef o
statü yakalayabilecek çalışma temposunu
denizde başlattım 8 dakika altı saniye
dünya rekoru e dört buçuk dakika üzerine
çıkamıyor Çünkü Çanakkale suyu 12 derece
14/13 derece o suyun içerisine
yapıyorsunuz Çok çıkıntılı bir ortam ve
doğru odaklanma yapamıyorsunuz hareket
var sürekli ve hipotermiden dolayı da
fazla Deniz dek alamıyorsunuz yani suyun
sıcaklığıyla dengenizi sağlamıyorsunuz
ve nefes tutmakta metabolizmayı çok
ciddi derecede ağırlaştırdı içinde
maalesef hızlı adaptasyon sağlıyorsunuz
ve odaklanmanızı kaybediyorsunuz İşte bu
süreç benim için bir buçuk ay boyunca
maalesef sıkıntılı gitti ama bir buçuk
ay sonra bir telefon geldi ve bu telefon
o orada açılan yeni bir otelin genel
müdüründen geldi dedi ki böyle bir
girişimin var ve biz Otel olaraktan seni
desteklemek istiyoruz bizim havuzumuz
var bu Havuzun imkânlarını lütfen kullan
ve bu imkanları İnşallah dünya rekoruna
da çevirirsin
bu açılışı da seninle yapalım
şimdi Evet duymak istediğim bu süper bir
anda ne oldu deniz sıcaklığı 14
dereceyken hava sıcaklığı 29 dereceye
geldim bir anda çarpıntılı sudan Sanki
kendi özel Havuzun Muş gibi bir havuza
geldim sabah-akşam kesmeden antrenmanlar
başladı ve inanın 15 gün içerisinde
Hatta yirmi gün içerisinde diyelim 7.30
dakikalar yakalamaya başladı Yani
potansiyel var kafada sağlar artık
tamamiyle derece akışa girmeye başladı
ve her gün
Çanakkale'nin yolcusu ve Poyraz'ı hiç
kesilmez ve lodosta Derler ki Lodos
balığı bile yenmez işte ben lodosta bile
yedi buçukta kadife tutabilir hale
gelmişti bu dünya rekoru da çok yakındım
ama hiçbir zaman yani hiç Daha yeni bir
dünya rekor denemesi olduğu içinde ne
yapmam gerektiğini acaba rekoru geçeyim
veya da geçmeyeyim mi tarzında hep
kafamda bir soru işareti vardı ve dedim
ki ben bu rekoru yapacaksam dedim zamanı
anın içerisinde yapayım ve Ve o an geldi
altı aylık süreç 5 Şimdi size o anı
anlatmak istiyorum O Havuzun içerisine
bir tek ben varım
Yurtiçi yurtdışı gözlemciler Yurtiçi
yurtdışı basılsın Çanakkale'nin bütün
Protokolü Havuzun içerisinde
Tabii ki ailem havuzu içerisinde ama en
önemlisi şu havuzu içerse bir tek ben
varım bu inanılmaz bir şey kurbanlık
koyun gibiyim ve Havuzun içerisinde o
nabzı düşüremiyorum
Sen bana şimdi söyleseniz size stres
yönetimini saatlerce anlatabilir çünkü
işim bu ama ho anda hiçbir şey
bilmiyorum Ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum
kalbim ağzından çıkacakmış gibi ama
odaklanmam sadece ve sadece tek atımlık
kurşun
İşte benim için gerekli olan en önemli
nefesi çektim ve kendimi o beğenilen
şans noktası içerisinde suyun akışına
bıraktım Evet akışına bıraktım diyorum
Çünkü 7 dakika hayatımdan nasıl geçti
hiçbir şekilde bilmiyorum
protokol noktası içerisinde omzunda bir
el dokundu Bu dekordan bir dakika
herhalde okunması gereken
eldivenden Tabii ki bir anda irkildim
saatime baktığımda da zaman 7 dakika
yediği gösteriyordu yani 8'de kaldı
saniye nin Aslında protokol zamanıydı ve
anlam veremedim çünkü ne diyafram
kasılması ya ve o anda yapamayacağına
dair hiçbir belirti yok vücutta ve akış
Gidiyor Ve tabii ki bunu düşünürken ve
bu şaşkınlık içerse bir dakika da şak
diye geçti bir anda oldu artık dünya
rekoru üzerinde 8 dakika 7 saniye artık
ne zaman çıkmam gerekiyor diye bekledim
Back İşte o çıkma anında Suyun dışına
çıktığımda
Bu hakemlerle yani gözlemciler ile karşı
karşıyayım ondan şaşkınlığı Tabii ki
benim de şaşkınlığın Çünkü çok rahatım
ve zaman ne bilmiyorum ve bütün havuz o
kadar kalabalıkken çık yok herkes benim
Okey vermem bekledi kendimi toparladım
bu ayın okey dedim yani İyiyim ve 25
saniye geçtikten sonra bana beyaz kart
gösterildi Yani artık o yapmış olduğum
rekor ofişıl hale gelmişti ve yapmış
olduğum dakika ise dokuz dakika otuz
saniye dedi yani 8 dakika altı saniyelik
dünya rekoru bir buçuk dakika daha
yukarıya çıkmıştı ve Tabiki beklediğim
Umut ettiğim eşofman ise bana
Yurtdışından bu rekor vasıtasıyla geldi
mi Evet sekiz yıl bekledim sekiz yıl
vazgeçmedim sekiz yıl dik durdum sekiz
yıl her soluduğum Hava da her attığım
kulaçta her akıttım perde şu söyledim
Bana bu şans verilecektir
bu ve bu Sekiz yılın sonunda
12 resmi dünya şampiyonu bir Sualtı
Olimpiyatları Şampiyonu iki Avrupa
şampiyonluğu 12 resmi dünya rekoru ve
iki resmi Avrupa rekoru kırdım Evet
da kaybettim gibi geline sekiz yıl
Aslında kazandım dediğim ama dönüştü
Sen beni dinlediğiniz için de size
sonsuz teşekkür ederim